huh  scp-914 the clock works one sheet of  eight and a half by 11 inch printing  paper with handwritten instructions  reading i would like a quarter pounder  with cheese no pickles no onions large  order of fries and a medium pepsi was  placed inside on the setting of one to  one the output was the same sheet of  paper with the text i would like a  whopper no ketchup no mustard small  order of onion rings and a medium coke  the next sheet with the same  instructions was placed on the fine  setting it produced a stack of us  currency printed with pencil lead  equivalent to the cost of the food order  the final sheet also bearing the same  instructions was placed on the setting  very fine it produced a sheet of paper  inscribed with unidentified symbols  anyone who looked at this sheet of paper  reported a sudden craving for a  cheeseburger